back now with a look at the upcoming
trial of Navy SEAL Eddie Gallagher
accused by members of his own elite team
of war crimes killing an unarmed
teenager Isis fighter and randomly
shooting at innocent civilians including
an elderly man and a young girl Special
Warfare operator chief Eddie Gallagher
has denied the charges and says the men
in his unit alpha platoon SEAL Team 7
are lying about him the investigation of
Gallagher began after he was accused of
stabbing to death this injured teenage
Isis fighter in Iraq two years ago seen
in this Iraqi TV video shortly before
Gallagher allegedly killed it other
allegations include times when Gallagher
in various sniper posts shot and killed
random innocent civilians and then later
boasted about it Gallagher was released
from custody two weeks ago and he and
his family have launched a campaign to
defend him outside court recently his
wife Andrea told reporters about the
pain she and the family are going
through called the kids yesterday and
just let them know the judge's ruling
and you know they just they all just
burst into tears it's a very emotional
thing for us to have to go through this
level of shame and this type of a
travesty but we're hopeful that again
it'll all come out we will be vindicated
his name will be cleared and everything
will be restored that's what we're still
hoping for the campaign to defend Gelder
has received extensive airtime on Fox
News where both his wife and his brother
Shawn have appeared Shawn what is the
evidence against your brother that at
trial nothing so there is none now I
don't want to seem like I'm glib or
coming off really quickly with that but
the allegations against Eddie are based
mainly on just words someone's word
against his the Gallagher campaign on
Fox News has apparently been well
received at the White House where
President Trump said recently he is
considering a presidential pardon for
Gallagher and we're joined now by the
lead lawyer for Eddie Gallagher Tim par
Latorre mr. Paula Terry thank you very
much for joining us are you set to go to
trial on Monday yes we are
is the evidence strong interview week
the evidence of innocence is pretty
strong the evidence that the government
intends to present I it was weak before
but it seems to be getting weaker by the
day are some of these former Navy SEALs
who were with Eddie Gallagher's unit are
they going to testify against him in
court we expect that a small portion of
the platoon is going to testify on
behalf of the government other members
of the platoon we expect will testify in
manners favorable to the defense and
we're certainly not talking about a
whole platoon that's trying to turn
their chief in we're talking about a
couple of disgruntled individuals this
has been quite a case with allegations
that the prosecution was involved in
major misconduct trying to spy on your
emails to the prosecutors have been
removed from the case what's going on
there well those aren't allegations that
was a finding by the judge the NCIS and
the lead prosecutor Chris Chappell AK
violated the fourth fifth and sixth
amendments by putting illegal tracking
software on to emails that they send to
defense attorneys and to a member the
media so as a result the lead prosecutor
was removed one of the other prosecutors
was awarded off by the Marine Corps but
the judge did not dismiss the charges as
you had asked so that trial will go
ahead the trial will go ahead you know
this is it's a serious charge it's a
murder charge so I recognize that ask
him for dismissal was a pretty tough
held to climb I think that he certainly
had the legal basis for it but he by
removing these prosecutors by then
releasing my client from custody
he gave us additional peremptory
challenges and he also took the maximum
penalty of life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole off the table so
we're set up in a really good position
to go into this trial but this is highly
unusual isn't it within the ranks of the
Navy SEALs such a tight group for one
group of men to testify against your
client it is unusual but I think it's
something that you're going to see be
seeing more of as we have the
generational gap between these younger
seals who
think that they know better than the
older more experienced leadership and
just because they can't get what they
want they feel like they need to go in
and make false complaints so you're
saying they're lying actually I I am I'm
absolutely saying that they're lying I'm
looking forward to cross-examining them
you know these are you they're supposed
to be our nation's elite warriors and
yet I look at NCIS videos of them crying
as they're telling stories that then
when you pull out the video of the
actual event they're clearly lying about
so I can't wait to get these guys on the
stand and you're gonna take them apart
you say absolutely absolutely we intend
to annihilate the government's case and
what videos do you refer to that you're
going to show there's plenty of videos
there's videos of immediately before and
immediately after the alleged incident
there's videos of like I said these guys
crying in an NCIS interrogation room a
year later as they're retelling this
false narrative so it's going to be
interesting to see how they can explain
that the false story that they used to
put my client in jail is so starkly
different from what the evidence shows
at the time and for the the testimony
they've given so far is that Eddie
Gallagher boasted of killing lots of
innocent civilians the the testimony so
far the only person that's testified is
the NCIS agent Joe where Penske and he
went in there and mischaracterized in
several respects what the witnesses told
him and so none of these witnesses have
actually ever testified now one feature
within the SEAL Teams and within any
special operations or combat unit is
that there's a lot of dark humor and so
to a certain extent they've tried to
take some of that dark humor out of
context and put it out there as if it's
backed and quickly president trotters
talked about a pardon any news on that
that my only source of information on
that is the news media we have not
reached out to the White House we have
in any way asked for a pardon you know
our focus is on going into the courtroom
and winning this in the court if
whatever the president decides you know
certainly I wouldn't want to dissuade
him from that but that's not something
we ever pushed for Tim Paula Tory thank
you very much for joining us you have
some busy weeks ahead